good morning thank you guys for coming
this morning just quick question show of
hands out of curiosity so how many folks
that worked in government like how many
folks work with some sort of government
entity agencies something sent and of
the folks that haven't raised their
hands how many folks have ever been
frustrated by the delivery of some like
government service all right there
forget it forget I get everybody else so
this this talk is not a particularly
technical talk I'm not going to be
walking through any sort of code
snippets or sort of talking in detail
about methods of a particular library
but more to sort of share an approach
that you know we're trying to use in
city government in Baltimore that I
think it's particularly helpful and make
start a conversation with other folks
that are working in and with government
around how we're using Python in certain
parts of this like toolkit so I want to
start our guests about telling us
sharing a story they get some brief
background on how we got here to this
talk so in 2012 after about three years
abroad in Mongolia working for the Peace
Corps you know I've been telling my
friends and family this is great I'm
done working in government
no more local government for me this is
it your prior to that I had worked for a
number of years for the city of
Baltimore as an assistant deputy mayor
and I was responsible for a lot of these
like multi-stakeholder multi-agency
process reengineering projects that
often part budgetary part legislative
and policy part process for engineering
and so it was fun but I had enough when
I was like I'm done
and so there's some very persuasive
folks in in in the city and by February
of 2013 I was back working in government
and this time I was managing you know
similar projects streamlined special
events establishing regulatory and
licensing frameworks for mobile vendors
and food trucks etc but if I felt
often like this this dude here in this
wheel there and there were a couple
challenges there were a couple
challenges or central frustrations that
sort of made me realize that there has
to be a better way to approach process
improvement for service delivery one of
those central frustrations was right
there's this unsustainable cycle that
you know we could never fix things at a
fast enough rate to get ahead of the new
problems that were popping up the second
was you know it was like you're chasing
this new cycle you know you structure
the you know processes or services that
you want to improve and you lay out okay
this month I'm going to focus on these
things and the next quarter wouldn't
focus on these things and then Sunday
some very clever well-informed
journalists or institutional leader
would publish an article about something
and you would just blow up your plans
because priorities were shifting that
you're working on sort of different
things so that was one critical problem
that we need to solve the other was that
and this is central to this talk there
was often a very sort of small and
familiar base of people that were the
problem solvers across agencies so like
whenever we would run into some sort of
public service delivery problem or
business process problem in government
it was the same set of sort of small
folks working on solutions for these
issues so there's the the base was sort
of fixed so I guess that gets into the
audience so who was just talked for
right anyone that's in any of these
spaces for any level of work but
especially the folks that are either
working in government or working with
government and you know the process
improvement or performance management
side of things and you're looking to
build a team or small team to have a
disproportionate impact on the way you
guys do service delivery and maybe
you're thinking about trying to use
Python to establish sort of a lingua
franca on ecosystem to drive all the
process improvement in your units and
oriented team around that so this this
the audience for this talk is sort of
get geared at that
one of the reasons is that we took this
approach and partly it speaks to a
challenge is that you know we were
saying this there's a disproportionate
focus on sort of public service delivery
right everybody's interested in the end
point of service delivery to the public
if it's public safety folks are
interested in police departments and you
know fire response towns if it's you
know services to the public it's people
were interested in you know the
permitting or the licensing or you know
Sanitation Solid Waste Services but
there wasn't enough focus on that
important internal service delivery
between agencies right so like if you're
one agency and providing service to
another the buttress or to facilitate or
to enable another sort of public facing
agency to provide service like that's
where that's where a lot of the magic
was happening and it wasn't enough focus
or sort of unifying language around
process improvement in that space to
really leverage making government
delivery service better for the folks
that are receiving it on the public in
so those are some of the challenges and
this speaks to this is just some context
on our sort of agency and organizational
structure so the folks that are working
in and with government can sort of add a
contextual layer to that don't worry
about all the other stuff that's missing
cos not important city you have your
your primary just like you know mayoral
office or whatever your sort of center
of government is and then you have at
that next level all the agencies and so
the agency where I work is the
Department of General Services is sort
of like GSA at the federal level but for
the city so we're responsible for
providing the internal services to
support government agencies so we have
division responsible for managing
facility and building maintenance so if
there's any building that houses
delivery of public service
if City Hall Housing Department you come
to get permits health centers police
district headquarters maintaining the
building's the same similar
responsibilities for fleet if there's
any vehicle that is used to provide a
public service we have
low Packers dumpsters haulers boats
police cars whatever and so those
there's a lot because of that there's a
lot of it there's a lot of opportunities
to see the how effective or ineffective
business delivery services and so our
office the business process improvement
office is in that unit in that agency
and we're not a consulting front we're
government with government employees but
we sort of function like sort of
performance management process
management consultancy inside of the
agency that's focused on how all those
services get delivered so that's I guess
context for this talk so we we
structured the office and the the sort
of primary goals around trying to arrive
at like again this lingua franca for
process improvement so the primary
focuses were are you know how do we
eliminate paper all paper all
paper-based processes for all of our
agency operations within a four year
period that's number one - you know how
do we build a sort of talent pipeline
that leverages national and regional
institutions academic partners research
startups nonprofit etc how do we how do
we sort of build that framework and
leverage it to support pillar one and
pillar three and then third is this task
automation engine so that's a lot of
where this this talk sort of is derived
from which is how do we steal back the
way we talk about it in offices how do
we steal back time and give it to
administrative staff and so that's
identifying all manual repetitive
administrative research analysis
processes and then automating those and
then using Python and sort of having
that be the sort of central language and
other toolkits around the I guess the
common languages and libraries that
people use how do we establish a similar
communication system around doing these
three things and so this is I guess the
question that I want to walk through and
sort of start a conversation on that
that was really helpful for us which was
if you you know you're working in
government service delivery and you're
trying to build a team to have
disproportionate impact you know what
approach did you take and what do I need
to consider if I want to establish like
a shared language and shared language
and a shared culture for process
improvement for office and I know I'm
talking a lot about the office but you
you'll see later that we this this sort
of approach seems to work for us at
least seem to work if it's the focus
isn't just on your unit on your team but
rather the city but like building a
building an infrastructure that's human
capital and culture related to really
force a sort of shared language across
the city or across whatever your
government entity organization is to get
people orient around that and change the
way they think about process improvement
so these are the things that we we were
like okay well we need to the roadmap
isn't clear but we need to think through
these things and how these sort of
variables impact you know what tool will
arrive at not just what - what language
you know what libraries like what do we
use whether we pay for we sort of needed
to know we narrowed it down to say okay
these are the areas that we need to sort
of focus on and some of that would drive
like what sort of technical skills that
we need to attract but we need to answer
a lot of these questions before we got
there give me one second I'm fine -
these
so this is like a basic sort of this is
after our sort of internal analysis of
like what business problems we had and
how to build this structure this is what
that sort of in roadmap looked like it
was you know we we needed to start with
what business problems we we had today
so I walked through later like what the
three key steps are for us to sort of
establish is called this this instrument
one was assessing what the business
problems are and figuring out how those
impact each of these other elements to
arrive at the tools and if this question
is later I don't want this this could be
a separate I guess conversation but I
wanted to sort of put this up in case
questions that I focus at are working in
government have questions about how we
sort of navigated each of these things
to arrive at a particular lingua franca
set of tools for process improvement for
the agency in it for the city one other
I guess key sort of decision points for
us was that this was not our universe
and but when I say this was not our
universe I mean you know the types of
problem after we did this sort of
solicitation and analysis of the type of
business problems and service delivery
that we were seeing we recognize the
like this not only was not our problem
universe it wasn't a skill set
it wasn't our wheelhouse right so we
weren't you know the folks that we were
working with in the office to not stand
I'm not a statistician about training
right we're not sitting around the lunch
table having debates about you know
what's the best practice to avoid
overfitting in your models or you know
what are the best algorithms to use
based on the question type of the
character character versus the data that
you have so that wasn't us right so we
we knew that if we were going to build a
team to focus on process improvement we
needed something that was
general-purpose and so I guess that's
the nice way to say this is why we took
the partner right not the RO if people
ask those sort of questions even a lot
of the problems we saw the first step
was some sort of analysis task but we we
recognized that there was enough
in the ecosystem to support taking a
Python approach instead of this this was
what our problems most often look like
right they fell largely into three
categories the first was you know
something is something's not happening
it's like hey something's not happening
and it should be happening right that's
the first category vision problems that
we saw the second was hey something is
happening and we wanted to stop but
found out why but first before you doing
they make that thing stop happening
that's happening and the third sort of
category of these business problems we
were finding was we you know we assume
or we believe we should be doing X but
we don't know when X is happening
because you know so-and-so doesn't have
the time because some soils doing y&z
repetitively all the time and so is
there a way to sort of free up this
person's time to do this other test to
help detect when this thing is happening
so these were the sort of three I guess
categories of business problem that we
were seeing is that okay not only do we
really need to focus on Python at the
general-purpose language but there's a
specific set of libraries and tools that
we need to be gearing people to and
around based on what all sort of problem
landscape looks like I guess another one
of the key decision points that we made
was you know there's a lot of people
often it's often in a negative context
when people talk about you know if you
have a hammer and that's the only tool
you have then every problem looks like a
nail
we actually wanted to take advantage of
that we wanted to sort of force everyone
that not only was working on the team
that we're trying to build but also the
we wanted to force the conversation
across city government that hey you all
you have is a hammer and his hammers
free and as a huge community that's
building tools for this hammer so you
need to see every problem as a nail any
problem that you come across is a nail
and so the question should be okay how
can i leverage Python to solve this
particular problem right to sort of
speed up the communication across not
only our unit but the non-technical sort
of non programming people across city
government across
so we were really trying to take
advantage of this oh this is your hammer
every problem you see is a nail so that
also reflected you know what are our
sort of grouping or benning's of the
business problems were in the Riesling
service delivery so I talked earlier
about how we went through this road map
and we started with what are the what
are the business problems that we have
to the sort of solicitation process and
you know what are the what can we safely
anticipate about the types of business
problems that we're going to see
tomorrow and and some of this for the
folks that are working in government you
may you may sort of inform some of that
by if you're in a political office like
the person if governor mayor if they
have a particular agenda and they're
running on X Y & Z you you may want to
sort of feed that into you know how you
anticipate the types of business
problems for tomorrow but this is what
we this is what our sort of problem
University look like a lot of their
problems fell into these buckets around
analysis you know collecting information
that either was available and we
couldn't get our hands on or other folks
that had it didn't have good mechanisms
to get it to us for whatever reason but
we still needed it automating some
simple browser tasks these sort of mini
workflows data cleaning and reporting
and documentation so these were sort of
the the categories of the problems that
we had that forced us to sort of choose
a certain subset of tools for this like
lingua franca right just to give a quick
example like for context the reporting
and documentation we had and this may be
an example common across folks that are
working in local government no state
government you know we in the city used
this outcome based budgeting process
where you know you know budget
allocations to agencies aren't based on
just some sort of historical view of
okay last year you got X and we're going
to take inflation and 2% and colas and
you need negotiate this stuff and give
you this it's actually driven by what
are the key performance indicators
around your services five indicators for
your major services and then how do you
perform against those things so often
the allocations is tied to performance
and so
you have these you know annual and
quarterly metrics you need to report out
on and you know you'd get the
spreadsheets that are really complex and
people don't know what you know what's
going on in there
and so one of the first places that we
started with okay you guys have this
headache how can we how can we leverage
you know what parts are the Jupiter
notebooks can provide to give you sort
of reproducible you know well-documented
steps to reproduce this indicator for
you so that when you're gone and you
move on or that you're not the person
who you've got a promotion but now this
test comes around and they're pulling
you away because you have to reproduce
this thing so that's just like one
example but these were the comments or
the nails that we saw and so from that
sort of landscape of problems this is
what we arrived at focusing on for
process improvement we said okay folks
are going to use Jupiter and folks are
going to use Python alright that's a
given base and in those internally
within our team and within the people
that we work with and across the city if
anyone's you know sort of coming into
this ecosystem focused on these things
within the existing libraries you know
focus on these the ones in the green
because we know based on the type of
problems that we have today the ones
that we anticipate the categories that
they fall in the complexity of those the
frequency the volume of those problems
the potential impact of some of those
problems we know we're going to be
moving through file systems like
cleaning up stuff for people we're never
gonna have to schedule some tasks we
know we're gonna have to handle
passwords for some sort of you know
automating browser tasks we know we need
to send notifications to people right so
focus on those internal Python libraries
for the third-party libraries and
there's one here that's missing I didn't
a [ __ ] update in the bottom half which
is partly so that's the parent is numpy
matplotlib we said hey there's a wide
universe of really well maintained
awesome tools but we need to we need to
be going deep not wide in this case so
if we focus on these things we were
thinking about like what is the 80/20
right what are the what are the 80% of
I'm sorry what is it 20% that's why less
than 20 what is the 10% of
well-maintained tools if we're
establishing this ecosystem and this
tool for you like this is the vehicle
what are the things that we can use that
can help us solve or get us 90% away on
90 percent of the problems all right so
this this was sort of where we landed
based on what our landscape of problems
were not just the ones for the internal
service delivery between agencies but
the ones that we started to see we're
working across other city agencies so I
guess on the left side of the wall is
the stuff that we didn't pay for the
right side of the wall is the stuff that
we said okay we will invest in these
things and so this I go into this detail
because one of the things that we want
to do is sort of start a conversation
about if it's other you know government
institutions agencies that are looking
to do something similar you can sort of
I guess use this as a starting point
blueprint but so we paid for these
things right we the things on the bottom
the meet up and you did me I'm referring
to the sort of blue box with the red
text those were more cultural and out
and sort of human capital stuff and I'll
speak to those a bit later but this was
the I guess engine that we arrived at to
say okay Python is going to be the
lingua franca for process improvement
for the city this is it this is a
toolkit focus on these things any
questions of our good
so I guess one of the one of the
important things to figure out if you're
sort of we are walking through this
process is like what are the
considerations that I need to make be
aware of and what steps did we take to
sort of arrive at like using Python this
way as the engine for process
improvement across our agency and across
across the city
there's solicitation by that I mean sort
of sourcing the like the collection of
the business problems right I'm using
that broadly maybe there are analysis
problems there you know repetitive tasks
that people need to do like what are all
the things that either done less than
efficient or less than optimally and
what are all the things that are done
repetitively because we get equally
upset about those things right if
something doesn't function well and if
something is functioning well but it's
done in a way that's like many more
repetitive we equally upset about those
two things culture what are the what are
the steps that you you can take to
establish a culture around this or
they're self-sustaining and what are the
sort of human capital pieces that you
need to like put in place or steps you
can take to make this sustainable so on
I guess the solicitation is scoping and
make sure I get all of the just give me
one second so much of this we did
through our own sort of internal like
business process meetings you know we we
kept you know we set up a simple Google
form and allow folks outside of the
organization to say hey these are the
problems and we sort of built a
prioritization matrix around those and
interact those one other thing that was
useful was we started to follow around
and CFO it's like sitting on his meeting
he said hey we're just gonna follow you
because you pay for stuff and you see
the problems and people come to you for
solutions and you you get all the
consultant invoices so we're going to
follow you and sit on your meetings so
that we can get a better sense for also
like what types of problems it are
happening across the agency that was I
guess
one sort of helpful piece about the
solicitation of the business problems to
inform like what you want to put in your
toolkit if you take this approach the
second thing that was really helpful in
solicitation was you know going around I
don't know call them desk audits but
like going around your agency and
identifying those people that have-not
the messy desks because we don't want
the messy desks but the people that have
neatly stacked sort of piles of paper
because often for us that suggested that
these are people that are in some sort
of approval path that has some sort of
manual review or some sort of template
of opportunity to really dive in to
automate that process or sort of that
was often a good conversation point like
what you always have these like eight
stacks of paper of different height like
what's going on there so that was that
was helpful also solicitation point for
us culture there were a couple things we
did I want to walk through give me one
second so we did a couple things that
they were helpful one we set up a series
of lunch and learns and so these these
were free all right I'll speak a bit
later about the cost because one of the
I guess key takeaways is that the
barrier a primary barrier is not cost
which is I guess less important if
you're working on the profit side but if
you're working at you know you need to
justify your spending know that the
primary you know one of the primary
barriers is not cost so on culture side
one of the things we did was we set up a
series of lunch and learns for it that
was citywide and so we would the lunch
and learns weren't a direct a Python
punch in the face so hey a Mac plot a
punch in the face
we we would invite people that did
interesting things where the front of
the talk was in Python but Python was
the tool so for example you know we
invited you know a the head of a
regional sort of data firm to talk about
their work in developing Baltimore
neighborhood indicators and how they use
Python to do all the cleaning behind
there
we invited a PhD professor that is doing
really interesting work on the
predicting of stock prices based on like
Twitter sentiment analysis and he gave a
talk about you know how you could use
this sort of model to get us get a sense
for public perception about how the
government delivering services instead
he talked about how he used Python for
that so the the luncheon loans were hey
this is cool thing happening oh by the
way they use a Python for it right so
generate some interest we we also
reached out to like local software
engineers to say hey we know that folks
will need to if the end is ecosystem
need to understand what version control
is so we had them come in and do talks
on like what is github how do you use it
why does it save you headaches so those
sort of things were helpful oh the other
thing we did on culture was we as an
agency we we started a Python meetup and
so there are two Python meetups in so
there's one in Baltimore County and
there's one in the city the one in the
city is our Meetup and so this is for
its it's interesting it's a city run
meetup but it's for everybody right so
that the meetup will have you know city
employees across different agencies
it'll have you know researchers folks
from Hopkins Towson local nonprofits in
fact John who's presenting on Sunday he
he was the last speaker at our one of
our meetups and he gave this really
interesting talk about you know how to
use Jupiter labs and like how we use
partly so how how folks use and partly
for analysis that folks in our agency
and other agencies could really see okay
then I understand where they're going I
could see how these tools have been used
so those the meetups really the meetups
and the lunch of learners really help
with the cultural piece on okay toaster
culture on the human capital side we we
did a couple a couple things
second the time one was we began we
began to include Python teaching and
training in the job descriptions and the
work plans and the evaluations of
employees and sort of reinforced that
hey there's ecosystem and this is the
way that we expect folks to sort of
interact we we began to use the the
Python meat as a sounding board if we
were thinking about sort of
reclassifying a position or creating a
new position and we wanted to get some
sense for like the industries take on
that we would leverage also the Python
meetup to get information about okay
what do you guys and initially feel
about where we should recruit for there
so there's this position make sense so
does it drive with the challenges that
you see in we also one other helpful
thing in in this area we were able to
rely on sort of local software engineers
that are working in Python to to help
some of our own staff and other analysts
like overcome roadblocks right so there
were a lot of people that were like hey
I'm trying to deploy this thing and like
I keep running to this word error
because I'm trying to play around with
Heroku okay well we met this this this
woman or we met this guy two weeks ago
at this meetup and they seemed
interested and so you know we had
somebody that was maintaining those
relationships and those people were
willing to come in during their lunch
break with their time and sit down with
some of our team and other folks across
across the agency and say okay like this
is it was really facilitating the
transfer of like best practices right so
that was we're sort of leveraging a
resource that didn't belong to us to
help staff sort of get center around
this this this language this ecosystem
one other I guess interesting thing we
did on the human capital side support
this was we started to set up these
relationships with local and regional
partners one of those that is we
established an agreement a partnership
with its nonprofit coding schools that
does like you know after-school computer
science education for for high school
students and so we were saying hey the
pipeline you know we don't care if you
have a master's degree or your barista
but like can you do these things that we
need you to do so we went to them and
said hey if you guys can find a bunch of
smaller high school students we will
develop a curriculum for you based on
business problems that we have launched
it around like daily cleaning and some
sort of like not fully predictive but we
gave them some data problems and we said
hey we have a Python ecosystem hit the
curriculum have students work on these
projects will come in the evenings and
will spend time with the students to
make sure they understand the data set
and you know you guys hire professors
and it will we'll pass the money to you
and at the end we'll hire the smarter
student and so we hired this young girl
who was a 15 year old high school
freshman she's gonna be dangerous I mean
she was she we she's gonna be dangerous
anyway that was one example of some of
the human capital things that we did as
part of like reinforcing this ecosystem
so she worked on stuff for us using uh
she primarily am at plot Lib to do some
stuff for us so she was another good
addition to the team that's only human
capital side just a quick example I want
to give a brief example of let me check
the time you know sort of what this
looks like so the example is they're
going I want to give are not ones from
the folks that are working in the office
working on the team that have that our
programmers or have these things in
their job description or these are these
are their responsibilities I'm not
talking about those those people this is
not their work this is the sort of
non-technical people the folks that you
know the woman who is works in Accounts
Payable who was responsible for making
sure invoices got paid or supervising
invoices she took it on her own to you
know write a script that predicts or
doesn't predict that suggests where you
should go to lunch based on the sort of
available restaurants in the area
because there was a manual thing that
she saw every week every day somebody
was send an email less coffee walk lunch
let's go here so she said I couldn't I
can do that there was another guy who's
the deputy CFO who he's done a couple
things but just one example
there was a manual task for you know we
have the public spinning board you know
every Wednesday and this is you know
ninety to one hundred page document of
like all the spinning across agencies
and we would send reports to the
different division heads about like what
items on your document so he said well
let me just like pull this script this
PDF stuff put together summary send it
off to these folks right and so these
are not people that were like core team
but this is like hey they understand it
as an ecosystem there's like a common
language for process improvement and
they're looking at all these problems
and st. nails say I got it I got a
massive hammer how do I do stuff like
banging there on these problems and that
for us really sort of it elevated the
conversation about like identifying
business problems and people it changed
the way people talked about and
communicated about problems and
government people would then come us and
say hey can Python do this or compile
and solve that so then we knew okay
there's an underlying problem but
they're thinking about this in a way
that's going to sort of expedite the
sort of discovery process right and
sometimes they would even sort of take a
hack at an initial path which these are
just two examples to sort of speak to
what we were seeing got a little bit of
time left I think one of the underlying
principles was just this that we were
mindful that you know when when folks
initially comes the folks they don't
come from a programming background it
looks like the picture on the left right
like where do I start
just like there's a thousand things I
need to learn how do they all stack up
you know what's my entry point and so
our approach was we're going to lay out
for you based on the services we deliver
and the business problems that we
haven't anticipate these are the things
you need to focus on and really
communicate around these things and
don't worry about the massive universe
of everything else right so that really
helped us like being able to communicate
that to folks and I guess the last point
I want to make is the two takeaways here
are one that the barriers to doing
something like this are not necessarily
financial alright so we pay less than
that's annually we pay less than two
thousand dollars a year for the services
that we do
for all right so we we use github plotly
Python anywhere udemy and and you know I
talked about how we used to meet up
udemy has been really helpful because
now that we have this sort of shared
language and shared toolkit we can say
all right we're gonna pay for these and
the courses are really inexpensive with
high quality right we're going to pay
twenty dollars or fifteen dollars for
this course that you have forever and
that like you know in our one thing I
didn't talk about on the human cultural
capital side we we carved out these
Python support sessions for Python and
stuff in the stack we're Tuesdays at
2:30 and it's one conference room
it's you get somebody's let me working
on Python something like a side project
or something you working on for work and
then the folks in the agency that work
on it come meet there and it's
understanding across all the agency
supervisors that it's more valuable to
have someone sharpening their sword then
working on something else understanding
like hey if you have a lot of work this
is important so you can you can
participate and come core of all time
here so here udemy really helps us
I guess build a library of like
resources for folks so it there's the
limited number of things that we pay for
money is not the hurdle is the first
point the second I got somebody to take
away is that we saw a real benefit and
going deep brother than wide right just
like limiting the scope of what people
should focus on to force the
conversation and change the way they
think about problem solving and
government with Python and have it
become this like lingua franca so those
are goes to too many takeaways and
that's that's all I have I think I'm
good on time and we have I think nine
minutes for questions thank you guys
yeah I wonder if you ever sort of
focused on how people might change their
work processes to improve the use of
Python it's like they might store it in
a more open format instead of just in
PDFs and kind of trying to change that
yeah that's a that's a good point so
specific to PDFs we we haven't yet
largely because most of the problems
around the PDF space are hey I need to
do some analysis somebody just gave me
the stack of paper and I don't want to
spend two weeks typing up all the stuff
or you know I need to do this budget
projection and someone gave me this
amortization schedule and it's in a
scanned PDF and I can't I can't do
anything with it so that's that I think
I haven't seen that yet but I mean it's
a good question I would anticipate the
more we do this that folks will start
changing the way they work particularly
around storing documents but yeah I feel
like generally you should have your hand
slapped if you're still working on paper
stuff good question
such a quick question on culture
so yeah there colonization's is whenever
you trying to do this this large-scale
open-source internal technology
previously wasn't there
you should have lined up with dynamic
where everyone's trying to learn equal
learning the fastest start to look down
on people who haven't met back in
particularly when you start before 2002
people's performance evaluations there's
there's no financial incentives to learn
this name skill set really well how do
you I mean it's not it's not particular
to this this points tuition but exciting
because it's that know-it-all person
learned all culture specific problem and
how many sort of counterfeit or
supporting one another rather than sort
of taking water down yeah it's a good
question
we fortunately we haven't yet run into
that challenge and I think a lot of that
is attributed to not that we have built
good safeguards around that because we
haven't right we haven't built the
guardrails around that but we've just
been very fortunate that the I guess the
two folks at the leadership of the
agency that personalities are very
strong and they're very I got agency for
director agency director for example
will often walk around the the floor at
the end of the day and be like okay
who's working on analysis stuff like
who's doing what right so he's he's
pulling in people he's often given
shoutouts he's looking to see and maybe
he's aware of us maybe he's on it that
way he's looking to see who the junior
folks that are maybe you're an
accountant or you know maybe you manage
other field supervisors but you're
spending time on those Tuesday sessions
like how do I shout those people how do
I big those people up and so I think he
and also our CFO and myself our child
too we spend a disproportionate amount
of time sort of highlighting the folks
that are that we see the potential in
rather than the people that we based on
our observation of their personalities
would perceive to like be detrimental to
that sort of culture that makes sense
all right one more question
hi thinks for this talk today was really
great so first of all I'm very impressed
that you're getting the adoption of
Python within you know a worker base
body hasn't traditionally been open to
that kind of stuff and so my first
question is actually getting a sense of
scale and how many people have been
involved in this initiative and that the
second follow-on question is actually
more the use of goobie tools to kind of
extend this process without requiring
that same investment in learning
something like Python okay so I guess I
have a question on the second one first
what are I'm not afraid with goobie
tools what are go be tools okay Oh going
tools okay
which really is great website
yeah that's a good point that's not an
area that we focused on and maybe it's
one that we need to I think we need to
investigate more and that is to your
first question in terms of size our
office is right now it's three people
we're scaling up to add two more
so those three people are engaged in
those and then on the administrative
side we typically have anywhere between
like core regular people come into these
Tuesday and meet up things from our
office usually eight to ten folks across
different sort of work responsibilities
and then in the meet up for the luncheon
learns we have usually eight to ten
different agencies represented and those
range somewhere between twenty and
thirty people thank you guys
[Applause]